[Applause]  hello everyone out there in the  wasteland today sure I want to talk to  you about our world world you see now is  a very scary place democracy equality  and freedom all died with the bombs fell  we've been walking on their ashes ever  since especially here in Colorado  [Music]  the three children of our patriarch are  even more ruthless than he is we live in  a society built on violence  [Music]  but it wasn't always like this over a  hundred years ago everything was  different I believe we can get back  there if we fight the supreme  if we are fearless against the evils of  the world  we can be everything we were in 1987  [Music]  [Music]  that's our show for the day tune in  tomorrow and we're gonna talk about the  dangers of cannibalism played with xbox  game pass